hello everyone this is samir from audio
science review
uh true to our name i have a review for
you today and that's this gr research uh
little giant killer 2.0 lgk 2.0 kit
speaker
this was announced i think couple months
ago and there was fair bit of interest
because of the naming uh that you know
despite being a small speaker it
is able to compete or maybe beat even
higher end products
the price as you see is
depending on which capacitor you get um
it's between 289 and 313 dollars
and you might think you get this speaker
but you do not what you get is this
bag of parts uh you get two drivers and
uh two filters the
speaker and this driver
you can see it's a full range driver so
it's not a coaxial driver and that is
only got one binding post so you feed it
the full range sound and
you know you get a speaker
um
for reasons that the company explains
and i'll get into a little bit later
you'll you still need some filtering uh
components and and that's what these
parts here are for
um
now to to if if you're not savvy with
woodworking and good woodworking skills
because this is actually complicated
build due to sport you're gonna need to
order what is called the flat pack and
the flat pack is uh basically the
parts you need
the the wooden pieces uh the frame and
already machine holes and everything to
build the speaker and uh maybe this is a
better look of it well yeah no
um
on this thing so uh that cost you
another hundred dollars so you go from
you know if you get the fancy capacitor
you go from 313 dollars to 413 dollars
if you want to finish speaker as it
looks um then that will cost you over a
thousand dollars so
definitely not cheap a thousand dollars
you have a choice of incredible set of
speakers including some studio monitors
and what have you so
as a finnish speaker just the roi is
quite poor
on that as you'll see from that testing
and review
i requested a sample from the company uh
i tested another product from gr
research uh that actually did well but
post reviewed you know they and others
complained that the build wasn't right
and should have done this or done that
so i thought you know to avoid that kind
of headache i i see if they will send me
a sample uh that they built i only need
one speaker so it's even lower cost and
i'm actually happy to pay for it uh but
i wanted an official build from the
company uh you sent them an email and
danny uh
from gr research was the company conor
or co-founder answered and uh basically
said now
that
he doesn't see any need for somebody
like me testing his product um
i
wrote back that you know i'm going to
measure it properly and that
you know listen to it and he wrote back
that the
measurements that i make are no good
because he's already provided his own
measurements and that the way i do
listening test is uh what he called a
bit of a joke
and
that i simply wasn't qualified to test
his products
so i went ahead and uh
bought the kit and uh gave it to my top
diy builder rick sikora
rick has been diy speaker making forever
and he's built bunch of other speakers
for me for testing he's extremely
meticulous and he
really really tries to replicate the
design as it's meant if he has issues
he'll go back and actually ask questions
and what have you
and the process is open in that he goes
ahead and documents everything and he
posts this back in april so plenty of
time for people to look at and complain
or raise issues and none were raised
uh he is showing you a picture of the
components here that you get sans there
driver
this is the
driver as i mentioned uh you can see
again that it only has one set of
binding posts so you give it a full
range signal
um he pointed out that the inductor
quality was poor
and i fully agree you can see how it's
deformed uh you basically won't find a
proper inductor
all the layers need to be correctly
wound on top of each other
this thing is not round and the layers
are just you know splitting away from
each other um i have one in here but i i
don't know that you can see it um this
is uh he picked a better one of the two
for uh
um for the build uh and i'm looking at
this thing it's got a flat thing in here
and the sides are just not even
uh
it's you know for 300 dollar kit i
expect really high quality uh
inductors in there
as you can see he actually went back and
asked you know what the issue was and
they were he was told that they were
having
issues with suppliers so
maybe they opted for you know a lower
quality supplier on this but uh it's
unfortunate
um
uh
the uh he by the way he measured it and
he measured according to the specs so
you know as far as that's concerned you
know
the build is as designed uh this is the
flat pack it's made out of mdf and this
is why i talked about the difficulty of
building this if you're a woodworker if
you're not a woodworker getting these
dados in there and precisely and
everything is non-trivial amount of work
in here
the whoever's doing the the work in here
has done an extremely good job on it and
this all
cut out with a cnc machine so once you
get the design right into the cad
program and the cam program
you can spit it out with very high
accuracy and really no complaints about
this other than the fact that the edges
are not rounded over if i go back to
this you can see the edges here sorry
the mouse keeps moving
you see the edges in front baffle are
rounded over unfortunately the kit as it
arrives you can see it's got sharp edges
and that causes diffraction so uh rick
had to actually get a router bit and and
uh make a you know a round over around
the corner as you can see in here the
original and then he had to uh smooth
the edges
and this is the complicated port
structures a little bit of a
transmission line-ish kind of thing
and this is what causes fair bit of
difficulty and for you to be able to you
know machine and do
cut this out yourself uh if you're
decent woodworking not a big deal but
anything beyond that you know you better
get the uh
you know get the flat pack and flat pack
is 100 well worth it um what you end up
with is the there's a speaker over here
a little speaker let me get it for you
it's extremely dense and heavy courtesy
of of the mdf that's very very thick for
this class of speaker this thing is not
going anywhere you can drive a tank over
it
and nothing will flex now whether you
need such a stout enclosure for such a
little driver with so little capability
to pump out you know the air
uh is to be debated but certainly uh you
know it's over designed from that point
of view and uh the build is superb
everything fit perfectly it just you
know rick's done a fantastic job in here
so let's get into the review um
you can see up here i put the fact that
it's a joke to uh as a
line that
danny gave me anyway this is the speaker
again uh this is the backside he uses
these tube connectors that normally
danny has an up charge of i don't know
50 60 dollars for and uh basically it's
banana jacks without spring loading and
this time they were included as unusual
usually that's an up charge you can see
the tight nice finish of this back panel
is actually quite stiff it doesn't even
need the screws almost to hold it back
you might think well this is an ultra
small speaker and there's no competition
there's actually plenty of competition
for small speakers this is a neumann
caged add dsp one of the best small
speakers i've ever tested uh it actually
costs the same as uh the geo research
lgk 2.0
except that it also comes with
amplifiers built in it's an active
two-way and it's got rule of flat
frequency response and
it's actually a little bit smaller i do
like small speakers for my desktop and
uh
so from that point if you appreciate the
goal that uh gr research has in building
a small ones a lot of times studio
monitors are just way too deep to put on
the desk or way too large
anyway let's jump ahead and
look at the measurements uh
the overall frequency response actually
fairly flat if you step back and ignore
the little wiggliness in here
it's pretty good other than this peaking
over here
at the end
but this kind of little variations here
and there you know exist in many
speakers
except for those active dsp ones that
tend to correct for those things but uh
i'll get into more of what these are now
if you go look at danny's announcement
video you'll see that he posts a
frequency response and unfortunately
unfortunately for him it looks nothing
like the one i'm showing you right
so at first glance you might say whoa
the build is wrong and this can't be the
you know this you know you haven't built
it correctly well
if you look at the two clues in here
you'll see why his measurements are so
different for one thing he's using a
one-third octave smoothing that means
the high resolution measurement was
reduced filtered tremendously down to
only one-third of an octave
to get this graph and what that does is
that it gets smoothes all these
variations all these vanish because
they're two you know when you average
these things out this becomes more or
less a flat line
and the other thing is that this is what
is called a gated measurement which
means that he doesn't have an anechoic
chamber nor does he has the have the
hundred thousand dollar measurement
system i have for speaker measurements
so he's going to get reflections from
his room so he basically uh has a
time value that says all right measure
only for as long as it takes for the
sound to reach the microphone and then
stop that eliminates the reflections in
the room but what it also does is that
it severely uh lowers the resolution of
the measurement so he is wise to not
even show you anything below 200 hertz
uh because there's no resolution there's
all smooth and bogus and for this kind
of measurement uh is actually probably
not accurate even up to a few hundred
hertz so probably four or five hundred
hertz up to here this is all way too
smooth uh on this thing so
if you uh rick was kind enough to take
my measurement and apply the same
smoothing as as his
and now you can see that they pretty
much match
each other and
you know same trough is in here you're
not going to get an exact measurement
because his samples danny samples
different than mine and acoustic
measurements are not that accurate if
you will but you can see the overall
shape is very much the same so the build
is matching that
now uh beyond using my expensive analog
uh speaker measurement system for uh uh
you know full uh 3d uh
uh dispersion of the speaker i also put
the microphone directly close to the
drivers and the port and see what we get
and
we see that we have two components that
generate sound the port and the speaker
itself here's the speaker response you
can see over here uh and it's a full
range so it keeps going i'll show you
later on what's causing these two things
in here
but then we also also measure the port
the port
is as you can see it's providing base
enhancement so where this thing would be
rolling off there's a resonance in there
that causes this port to boost this
these frequencies up and then what you
hear is the sum of these two so the
speaker now goes from
150 hertz uh you know response now you
can go down to 70 80 hertz so that's
what ports do
but unfortunately the other thing they
do is that they let out whatever
you don't want from inside of the
enclosure out in this case the cabinet
dimensions cause resonances inside and
uh we can see that resonance where the
port ideal port should just do this and
die off but it actually gets a second
life and starts to uh
generate the pretty loud resonance from
internally and then this gets summed
with this and causes this kind of
disturbance that you're seeing here and
this is unfortunate because it's a very
critical area of uh for music and
hearing is one to two or three kilohertz
hearing is very sensitive a lot of music
contents in here and this is what is you
know you get mid-range coloration it's
called because of the ports almost every
port causes this but smart designers are
able to suppress this a lot more or pull
it further back so that where the woofer
is much more dominant on this thing
letting it come in here when the you
know the response is getting lower and
then this thing you know has as much
better chance of competing with that
than polluting that now again this is
typical so you know it just happens i
should say that padding material was not
provided
but was recommended and rick did put the
padding in there and so without it this
may even be worse than worse than this
okay
um early reflections is uh
uh basically the most important
reflections that you're likely to hear
beyond the direct sound and ideally it
would look like this red line that i've
drawn in here and this more or less does
that except towards the end also the
response drops off the response drops
off is because this is acting like a as
an awfully large twitter and because of
this large size it actually starts to
beam the high frequencies start to
narrow and that narrowing causes the uh
sound that goes off axis to be to have
much less power so if your hearing is
very good uh and you go way up to 20
kilohertz you'll find that if you then
move your head left and right you will
lose on that high frequency so generally
not a good thing to happen but
you know it's not end of the world we
combine everything together
and
we say how would this sound in a typical
room and we see that it's actually quite
reasonable other than this drop over
here
it's reasonable i can't complain about
this being an issue
because i measure a lot of speakers some
are much worse than this so overall not
a big problem
um this beamwidth um
shows you the effect that i talked about
notice that we have the uh the basically
equal amount of energy up to about four
or five kilohertz then after that the
the driver what we call beaming it
starts to become like a flashlight and
narrows down that was the effect that i
talked about and it follows this precise
logarithmic curve in here so when you do
a log scale in here becomes a flat line
and you can see
the you know follows the physics that
mandates that happens so there it is and
you can see it pictorially better in
here with a
colorful measurement here by the way i
plan to do a much more deeper dive video
on how to read these graphs and how
speaking measurements work so for now
just focus on high level message that
this thing becomes very directional at
very high frequencies
the real issue manifests itself in
distortion measurements i usually
measure the speakers at 86 db and 96 db
little smart speakers and things can't
handle 96 go down
in this case as at 86 it already the
situation was quite dire with the
speaker you can see that we're off the
scale my scale goes up to five percent
and not usually expected to do that at
very low frequencies but here we're
seeing that even at 500 400 hertz we're
already off the scale and
if i change the scale from 5 to 100 we
can see that we basically have 100
distortion uh over here and even here
like or three hundred hertz we had ten
percent distortion the problem that
distortions that got harmonics that
spray in here at higher frequencies and
they then interfere with the region
that we are hearing is quite sensitive
uh we're not sensitive here but we are
sensitive to what happens here and
this can have audible effects
but
these things are not directional they're
directional information they chd
measurements
they're not psychoacoustically accurate
unless you apply the explanation i just
gave and
the ultimate test of this actually is
listening test uh you might think that
we're all about measurements no there's
a reason i listen to every speaker
because distortion is something you can
assess pretty easily with your ear well
if you have good good hearing so let me
move on if i plot the distortion at uh
as an absolute value rather than
percentage and i went from 86 to 90 db
at 90 db the driver was already starting
to crackle at some frequencies so i
didn't there going above 90 db but even
at 86 db i draw this 50 db line where i
like to see everything below that and we
already see that in this region we're
already way above it again we can ignore
the low frequency ones and here it gets
very close to the threshold at 90 db
it's already
way above i mean this is just unusable
and on this thing
i
also made the impedance measurements and
phase measurements and
my measurements here are extremely high
resolution and accurate so as a result
it shows very minute detail that you
don't normally see in this kind of
measurements because normally you don't
care about
very fine variations another reviewer
that was in the thread complained that
the build must be wrong because he's
never seen this well you know if you set
up a very high resolution impedance
measurements which requires about half a
dozen parameters being said right
you do get this and i've seen it in
other speakers as well
good news here is that danny tries to
keep the impedance high which means that
it's easier on amplifiers you don't need
as much current and he's achieved that
with a six ohm
minimum impedance in here you can see it
over here so good job there on that
i'm not too worried about this right now
um waterfall display uh this is a good
teaching moment on this graph uh if i
run this thing the way i normally run it
basically this is frequency response
over time so the top line is basically
what you saw earlier but then we keep
scanning uh
numerically not physically numerically
when we're able to find these extensions
in here which means that when a
node plays in here it actually hangs in
the air and it keeps takes a while to
dock an ideal speaker would just have
this being flat and
every one of these things is is what we
call resonance which means that the
thing plays its own tune after you stop
you look at this just as the frequency
response test indicated all sudden you
say well that doesn't look anything like
danny's thing because danny's one you
know looks like this basically shows
almost no resonances there's one in here
it shows and maybe tiny one here but
it's all clean and he raves about how
clean it is
but
look i can get exactly the measurement
that he has just the same how did i do
that i just changed one number in the
settings for this graph which was to
move the noise the floor of this
measurement
just 4 db higher so what it did was that
it all sudden sliced off all of these
low amplitude resonances so if you just
bring the floor the carpet up then all
the wiggliness becomes below it and it
disappears this is the reason i warn
people to not fall in love with this
waterfall display it is so easy to lie
with this graph and show extremely good
performance or i could actually go the
other way and show millions of
resonances in here it's a judgment call
of what you pick um best use of this
this kind of measurement is actually for
design usage when you're not trying to
lie to yourself or somebody else and
you're searching for problems and in
general doesn't tell you anything useful
anyway because these resonances are
caused by these peaks over here and you
can see every time i have a peak in here
i have a corresponding uh
you know time uh ringing so the
frequency response already told you that
look at this peak over here and you can
see that it extends in time as well so
by just looking at the frequency
response you can tell where the
resonances are you don't need this fancy
display that can lie to you this way and
indeed we look at his display all of
these are resonances in here yet he
shows no lingering uh tones why because
he has just 25 db of dynamic range in
here his floor is way up and so
therefore his measurement's not
sensitive enough to show that
anyway step over the
step response
post a review
that i post in writing a week ago i made
a uh electrical uh measurement of the
network test in there i uh
put a probe around the speaker terminals
and ran a sweep and we can see basically
the uh what the two what the filter
components are doing first one is what's
called the baffle step compensation
which he talks about in his video danny
does and that's basically an amplitude
rise at certain frequencies that get to
be the size of the
uh front of the speaker and so you need
that otherwise you get a boost in that
region and the second one is this notch
filter that is put in there why is the
notch filter put in there if you look at
that the measurements of the driver
itself which uh
gr research post so you can see that the
response gets screwy over here you'll
have uh some loss of energy in here then
it got some peaking
looks like he's attempting to bring this
part of it down the problem with that is
that it's got a very narrow notch and
there are part variations out there
where you can't
time or ju you know match this against
such a weird shape of stuff with active
dsp or software dsp you could have
corrected all of this
it would still take fair number of
filters and the problem with passive
components is that every filter costs
you a good bit of money because you got
expensive components software dsp is
free
danny doesn't believe in software dsp
which is a shame because this is
extremely powerful too anyway he
attempted to correct for this but it
didn't correct because if we go back
sorry about scrolling on you um
we can see that
this whole peak is in here and this
glitch in here so
that notch filter might as well not be
there it's also too narrow to be
perceptually
audible or hearing uh the bandwidth
resolution of it
gets quite poor at very high frequencies
so
you know you could have a broad filter
for all of this where you just flatten
this whole hump and it'll be much better
than trying to put a notch filter in
there and incur so much cost in in parts
okay
so
those are the measurements but the punch
line actually in this case is not
measurements i listen to every speaker
and the top thing i listen for is
distortion because as i mentioned
distortion measurements are directional
but your ear if they're trained and you
know what to look for you have the right
material you have right set up you can
actually you know hear and verify that
what the problem is and based on
tonality i expected the speaker to sound
good uh the distortion was worrying me
but i wasn't sure at what point it was
gonna uh kick in so i played the track
at the beginning it was okay and quickly
the sound became garbled
and it got garbled in vocals
but in a special situation and uh
after i did the review people said can
you post some samples well here's a
bonus for you i went ahead and
set up my earthworks measurement
microphone put it in front of the driver
i use a rme babyface
adc and microphone amp to
capture that and you get to listen to
that you hear
exactly what i heard so let's do that
[Music]
once our romance was a gay thing
now i am only your player
i know it's all unfair
but i'm too much in love to care
with every kiss you deceive me
sooner or later you'll leave
so here i started at very low volume at
the beginning the volume is just too low
to listen to other than maybe background
music and so what i was doing i was
gradually increasing the volume and you
can
hopefully you heard about a third in the
in there uh you already started to hear
her vocals started to tremble and from
then on just keeps getting worse and
worse and worse and towards the end
before it got really way too loud it
started the driver started to crackle
but well before that you already had
that problem let me play it again for
you
once our romance was a gay thing
now i am only your play thing
i know it's all unfair
but i'm too much in love to care
with every kiss you deceive me
sooner or later you'll leave me
so
then you skip to another track and this
problem won't be there what is it
why is it here not on some other tracks
what is happening here there's a set of
drums that are playing and then she
sings over them the drums cause
large excursions in this little driver
forcing it to get severely distorted and
then the highs are riding on top of that
and you're getting into modulation
distortion and that's what's causing the
vocals to distort also because a driver
is way non-linear already and it's
operating in a bad uh
region now if this was a woofer and you
had a separate tweeter a two-way speaker
that wouldn't happen because the twitter
is not impacted by the distortion of
woofer but when you take a single driver
and have it play full range
then you buy the distortion at low end
that impacts the the higher frequencies
so
to me this was totally totally
unlistenable speaker
and by the way listening setup was just
like you see it here a little bit past
an arm's length and this is where i test
a lot of the near-field speakers i also
put them on my desk over here but the
nice thing about this setup is that
there's no desk in here so avoid the uh
bounce from the desk and uh
i've tested a ton of speakers in here
none have ever ever ever distorted at
low volumes like this
and the problem with distortion is that
it's a learned skill once you hear this
distortion as you just heard
and you turn the volume down
even when you get to the minimum volume
you can still hear the distortion now
because your ear truck got trained now
it knows what the distortion sounds like
and uh
it refuses to not hear
and
so this was a problem so what i did was
to verify this was that i put extremely
sharp filter in there to chop off
everything below 80 hertz i think i put
in there yeah 80 hertz and once i did
that
wow all of a sudden you could get
decent sound was it still distorted at a
high
sound levels yes it still couldn't get
loud enough
but it definitely proved that you can't
allow to speak this little tiny driver
to play bass it's severely distorts it's
not made to be pushed like this to do
this and it just sounds horrid
you know tonality you could get used to
it you can use software eq to correct it
and here by the way i did fix the
tonality a little bit these two filters
did subtly improve the sound once you
had this in here but overall actually i
don't have complaints about tonality um
you know it has flat enough response
that that's not the issue
but to the extent you know it's just so
distorted it's an unusable design
um
one of the reasons by the way it's so
easy to hear the problems is because i
follow the research which says use one
speaker to do this kind of testing
danny ridiculed me for this but this
shows the power of research on why you
should do it this way if you play this
with two speakers
first what the left channel is playing
and what the right play channel is
playing they could mask distortions in
the other one
and secondly your mind starts to focus
on things like imaging and where the
instruments are and everything and you
get blinded by that effect and you don't
pay attention to fundamental issues of
the speaker
the research shows that as you increase
the number of
channels in a playback system listeners
get less and less critical about faults
of the
speakers indeed in the 5.1 setup
good and bad speakers are rated more or
less the same
on these things so this is why it's
important to
test a single speaker
the sound of a single speaker doesn't
change when you add a second one it's
still doing the same thing you want to
know if the design is fundamentally
sound and unfortunately this design is
not fundamentally sound for
something that if you bought the
finished one for eleven hundred dollars
it it just makes no sense i this ex
in my humble opinion
this speaker should not exist as a
product in the marketplace
because it's just a distortion factory
it doesn't play
at any volume anything decent i i
don't know what it's about i mean this
driver is the same size as what's in my
headphone
you know it's not made to be pulled down
to 80 hertz and try to produce that it
just this is something i'm sure it gets
sold to put in boom boxes or maybe smart
speakers which by the way almost always
have dsp and correction and limiters in
there to make sure it doesn't attempt to
all be overdriven in good designs trying
to put it naked in there without a
limited without the proper eq it's just
asking for trouble uh you know the world
of speaker making is not stupid it's so
much cheaper to build the speaker with a
single driver than this to make a
two-way speaker why isn't the world
producing speakers that look like this
they don't because it's not workable you
know this is the size of a mid-range
driver and a you know three-way speaker
is there's a reason we need a woofer in
there and a twitter and a crossover and
everything else
now if somebody wants to try produce a
good one yes do it but this design is
not it
i'm at a loss why danny didn't hear all
these distortions um
you know
maybe that's the reason he didn't want
to give me this sample i don't know
but i really really am disappointed that
he would put the speaker in the market
and rave about not only is the great
speaker in his own weight class but it
actually goes way above his weight class
and and outperforms things at much
higher price uh i'd much rather have a
you know
amazon echo playing music than this
thing or sonus or something else
this again
in my opinion
measurements show it my listening test
show it you now heard it uh it's it just
doesn't sound good by the way i waited a
week to do this testing because i
worried that maybe something had gone
wrong with the uh driver during my
testing uh measurements showed that the
frequency was everything else as i
showed were correct but i still wanted
to be sure so i had rick sent me the
second driver and i swapped them so
what's in there right now is a new one
and that's what you heard and that one
was never tested
until i put it in there on the exact
same problem as this one i measure the
dc resistance one of them is 5.3 on the
other one's 5 ohms so
very strange that they're they're not
even you know that accuracy the dc
resistance of these things so i've ruled
this out could something else be wrong
with this build who knows but you know i
tried i asked him for a sample
danny would just just was insulting and
would not cooperate so i'm out five or
six hundred dollars of my own money with
something that has unfortunately no
value and
i'm sure nobody wants to buy it from me
if you think it's the greatest speaker
please please come
and buy it from me i'm happy to sell it
to you for half the price and you can
play
okay hopefully uh
you got something out of this review and
saved you from making a mistake and
potentially buying the speaker okay
see you in a future video bye-bye